the Applegate River Lodge is located in
beautiful Applegate Oregon the lodge is
nestled amongst gorgeous Rivers Lush
Vineyards and boasts some of the
northwest's most stunning views owners
Joanna and Richard Davis build the lodge
22 years ago Richard actually designed
the large and built it having that much
workload a stress is just unbearable
once this labor of love was completed
Richard decided it was time to take a
break and relax
for 20 years
the couple got divorced so Richard now
lives on site in a hut next to the main
Lodge
my Giver name was Richard but at this
stage in my life I just got my papa the
Applegate River Lodge it's been a way of
life here for my family for about 22
years
right now my duties are making sure that
the energy that was given to me to
Stuart is here on the property at all
times
and yeah it's pot
grab my guitar
see where is my guitar while Richard is
looking for his guitar back on Earth his
ex-wife Joanna is desperately looking
for the money to keep the Lodge's doors
open we could easily lose anywhere from
five to fifteen thousand dollars a month
just because of lack of business
what's going on soon we got any
reservations coming up what are you
doing
I actually live in my motor home I
rented my house out did you need
something
you don't see the Apple gave me Reliance
it's a business never have never will
[Music]
all the pressure of running the lodge
falls on Joanna's shoulders she had High
Hopes her two sons Duke and Dusty would
take charge of the business I just
totally [__] disagree with what
you're doing should be none of your
concerns there's a big window you don't
have anything to do with this goddamn
restaurant but their constant fighting
has gotten in the way my brother and I
have a rocky relationship and let the
fist fights and all sorts of arguments
the brothers refused to work together so
dusty runs the restaurant and bar as a
separate business I'll grab you a menu
and we can get you something else with
his girlfriend I'm head chef hammy way
too much olive oil on them they turned
him back while Duke and his wife Melissa
used the hotel's lobbying as a concert
venue organizing Regular Music nights
how's everybody feeling tonight
thank you
foreign
Dusty's a lot more into deadlines and
numbers and I'm a lot more into feelings
and ideas and Concepts
a lot of people say there's too much pot
smoke and too much music too much of
this and too much of that too much fun
that's not my take on it
and if that's not enough of a headache
for guests trying to sleep Richard holds
after hours Jam sessions what time is it
what 111.
uh
I have had to cop some rooms here at the
lodge it was too noisy for them or they
didn't think the room was clean enough
ooh there's Spiderman all over it
so gross
I've had to cop quite a few rooms
unsurprisingly the Inn is hemorrhaging
money dragged down by a co-owner who
doesn't treat the lodge as a business
and two fighting Sons
if I can't get this family working
together their business is doomed
this Lodge is my life it's a legacy to
carry on through generations but the
family is so dysfunctional that Gordon's
just going to say you know what I can't
fix you guys we have to save the
business we have to save our family
I think Gordon's our only hope
my first time in Oregon beautiful
countryside
I'm on my way to the Applegate River
Lodge now if they've got a lodge here
and they're not making a fortune they
must be doing something seriously wrong
that is beautiful my goodness me
what's that dump and what's that smell
[Music]
are you ready to go back to sleep Troop
castling
wow hello
it's huge
but it's so empty
where's all the furniture and where is
everybody am I too late
wow
press the button for the buzz to summon
a human with answers you are kidding me
just relax I got to do exactly what I'm
doing
foreign
[Music]
it's like this place hasn't been
finished off inside hello
hello hello
where are the guests supposed to sit
[Music]
hey hey hello what are you doing
I I thought you'd gone no I was uh just
hanging out so I didn't catch your first
name Richard but around here they kind
of call me papa
around
do you normally run from desk there's
baldos to my room okay and then when
music starts coming I turn it over music
the music program we're gonna do tonight
it says the music there's a band playing
tonight yes
and then we'll probably jam out later
okay in the butt head what is the butt
hurt just help me would you like to see
the butt head uh I'd love to see the
butter okay yeah this is where you run
the reception from the butt Hut yeah
thank you
wow this is the butter this is where me
and troopy hang out
get up
smell what is that smell that's incense
they're right there incense yes that is
a strong [__] incense yeah Jesus yeah
but that doesn't smell like the smell
I've just smelled yeah it's herbs it's a
medicinal herb I love herbs especially
the freshness of them you can use it for
cooking if you want to do a really nice
fettuccine okay
was it like uh this is yeah it's like a
basil
wow it has a nice smell to it
[__] me that's definitely not basil
is this cannabis yes
so we smoke pot that's what I could
smell the minute I came in here yeah
what do you want me to do is this legal
here yes I use a medicinal herb
before you put your hands back in that
cookie jar do you mind if I see my room
it's a get a bit late
I'm done for a while okay yeah medicated
like you know so how do I get to the
room I'll show you
this is a first the owner of this Lodge
is as high as a kite wow look at this
place he probably hasn't even noticed
the place has no furniture
this is the Cattlemen room Cattlemen
room thank you yeah
it smells like cattle in here wow
what happened to the carpet the dog have
an accident you know we party a lot here
so you're gonna have liquor who knows
what's on these carpets right
what is that that's just bugs a bugs
bloody hell yeah
another crispy daddy long leg
that's disgusting
and this is your view out here
no I didn't notice the view because of
the carpet my God what a stunning
location it's Paradise it truly is yeah
I'll say I mean this place is stunning
shame is so filthy Richard
so the bedroom's up here right right
what in the hell has happened to this
carpet I haven't been up there in a
while there's more stains on this carpet
than inside Hugh Hefner's [__] wife
oh yeah I told you they party in here no
but how I mean how many come look at
this car every room's got those stains
on them you know what about the cover of
the bed when was that from 1970. you
have talked to Joanna about that John
that's your wife ex-wife thanks oh damn
yeah damn yeah she wants to be a
business which you should be it's not a
business to me
don't ask me finances because I have to
be lying if I told you I knew anything I
don't let's catch up later I'm gonna
have my bags okay okay thanks for the
update this place is disgusting wow and
it's hardly surprising seeing that the
owner doesn't see it as a business he
clearly doesn't care about paying gas
kids
don't do drugs and end up like that
[__] useless
I've just arrived at Oregon's Applegate
River Lodge hello the hotel lobby has no
furniture
it is so bear in here the rooms are
disgusting
it's like amazing and I've discovered
one of the owners is a Carefree hippie
it's not a business to me
Richard says his ex-wife is the
businesswoman here I hope she has a
better head on her shoulders hello
nice to see you nice to meet you so your
Joanna who was married to Richard
yes you deserve a medal and what'd you
do well let's see I check people in I do
the banking I'm the only one in the
family that's ever you know taken care
of the books and made sure that the
mortgage payment was paid why is it all
on your shoulders you just sound like
the only one who's actually in control
of this I'm the only one
no he's never even looked at the
checkbook
I'm really tired I'm getting tired of
holding everything up and it's getting
old driving through here those Vineyards
the mountains I mean you must be making
a fortune
well you know I'm
[Music]
a month this is crazy yeah but how can
the business not be in profit that's my
I don't know I understand no that's
that's what I need you for I honestly
having seen the lobby and my bedroom
yeah I can see why the hotel might be
struggling but surely the restaurant
must be making money with that view on
the river like that well the restaurant
is run by Dusty my younger son okay and
then Duke and his wife run the music end
of the building okay what percentage of
the profits do you get none
bloody hell it sounds nuts I know it
sounds like just crazy
wow I mean place
it's like a missed opportunity beyond
belief I mean I that's what everybody
tells me everybody says you've got a
gold mine here and I go well so far I
haven't found the gold
this place is a patch of Heaven
so I'm shocked to hear it's not making
money
I can't wait to hear why Joanna's Sons
aren't contributing to the lodgy's
finances
I see first name is Melissa Melissa cool
nice to see you too well hello how are
you likewise my pleasure good to see you
right yeah so this is set up for the
concert yeah I run the sound okay mixing
yeah okay great and how much does it get
in
it's 15. 15 yeah so out of that fifteen
dollars charge how much goes to Mum
none none well
let's let's have a quick word outside
[Music]
the place has got a million dollars
debts
yeah I know and it's and and I've been
sitting waiting and I I can I can relate
I think I know what's going on here when
was the last time how to smoke
way earlier this after the 20 minutes
ago no no no
this morning this morning
Dodger relieves stress but it definitely
smells of a business that's run by
Stoners yeah I know Duke isn't taking
any responsibility for the lodge
hopefully his brother will have a better
excuse for not sharing any profits with
his mum
Gordon wants to meet you
hello hello Dusty Dusty uh lucky Dusty
by the sounds of things oh yes of course
I would say hello hi Familia come here
nice to the chef right yes okay great
I'm a very hard worker I think Gordon's
going to like me uh so are you making
money here yes sir
how much money did you make a month uh
last month I made about twelve thousand
wow so you make about 150 Grand a year
with everything working right yeah and
you don't pay a dollar profit to your
mother
profit excuse me the business is a
million dollars in debt you make a
shitload of money and your mum gets
nothing
I was shocked that Dusty makes that much
and that bothers me because he should
help me out financially known for well
that you stand to inherit this business
there's still not a penny that goes in
to reducing debt and this is your mother
correct I really devoted my life to this
place and to be treated like I don't
care about my family and don't care
about this business it really cut to the
core I have no problem telling him to
get the [__] out of here I'll give a
kick with the ass if that was my son
I don't understand why the boys are just
ended for themselves why can't the
business work as one and everybody pull
together
[Music]
well you haven't done a damn thing
around here I work hard here and I don't
see you do [__] thing because you
can't take any criticism without wanting
to punch my [__] lights out
how do you feel about this shut the [__]
up both it's him he hates me listen what
would you like me to do I want to see
you grow up and turn into a real man I
want to see you like hire a [__] I
want to see you be able to go
oh my God no wonder this place is on his
knees [__] you
foreign
's Applegate Lodge and I thought the
answer for saving this place was for
everyone to work together you can't take
any criticism without wanting to punch
my [__] lights out but the boys can't
even talk to each other this guy tells
me my [__] brother it's clearly not
just the lodge that's falling apart [__]
you my God
people have heard about my visit and
both the hotel and restaurants are
booked for the night and right this way
guys I feel sorry for all of them hi
there come on over here I'll check in
how you folks doing tonight and I'm
sorry about the furniture in the lobby
they haven't got any please take a seat
on the stairs the guests don't look
impressed with the hotel and neither do
the customers in the restaurant but at
least they've got Furniture to sit on
here guys oh [__] that's right
appreciate it here for you guys
oh man okay fire up you got your tri-tip
I'm not looking forward to going to the
inner service with Gordon
um the interaction I had with him
beforehand I just know it's going to be
a nightmare everyone okay with it
my apologies
potatoes here and it's firing off guys
and we got creamed horseradish coming
around guys
the dog at the table is that normal
there the dog does it sit there like
that in front of customers yes sir
someone request them to stay some call
them over yes some customers call the
dog over oh yes of course the food's
that bad
while I'm trying to figure out what's
wrong in the restaurant guess in the
hotel are enjoying the unique charm of
the Applegate Lodge
Uber of some kind here you know look at
this you got your dry cleaner hangers I
just don't know about the bear though I
mean that's kind of oh my gosh where's
the TV
I hope the restaurant's better than the
rooms
okay I need that thousand island that
goes with this one here um ketchup
okay we're gonna catch up to a ranch and
that'll be a thousand right here okay
was that ketchup in this house yeah
[__] hell I can't believe this
restaurant is making money the guest
must be coming for the view because the
food is Dreadful
this is grilled salmon with pepper
pepper but it tastes like you literally
just sprinkled it with sugar the salmon
is frozen I'll be more than happy to
I'll just take that off here now
certainly I can't stand to watch another
minute of this thank goodness dinner
service is almost over because this
place is a joke yeah
got two minutes
I'm embarrassed I'm amazed you're still
open
there's no [__] standards in here I
don't believe that there's no standards
you've got a river running outside your
patio with salmon in it and you're
serving frozen salmon where's the
standard then what we do here is not
[__] you may be able to manipulate your
mother but you are not going to pull the
wool over my ass
because you're playing at runarest
that's been given to you you haven't
actually worked for this have you you
grew up here so hey mum I want to be a
Russian Turner this week without your
mother in this Lodge
you're [__]
[Music]
it's nearly 10 o'clock when many Hotel
guests will be thinking of heading to
bed but the music concert is just about
to start we've been doing this for 20
years we've been playing music I think
Gordon's gonna like it
[Music]
is
thank you
[Music]
I don't do drugs so I never thought I'd
see a dancing mushroom but I was wrong
[Music]
it's like the summer of love these
people are weird but they sure are
friendly
there we go
I love you too
is this a dream is this really happening
so are you checking in I am so sorry
welcome to the [__] mad house your
room is up these lost stairs right
behind you here
it's insane how guests are trying to
check in over this racket if I had
arrived to this I would have gotten on
the first plane back home
I don't think I'll be able to relax here
you can't really escape the sound
wow and the longer the music goes on the
more guests complain
[Music]
it's on me tonight okay we're gonna make
you happy no matter what okay okay all
right
with Joanna giving away rooms for free
the lodge is losing money pushing this
hotel further into debt
it's way past midnight and with a band
finally wrapping up it's time for me to
get some sleep before I dive under those
covers
I'm dying to see what's on top of them
that is disgusting I am not putting my
head on that pillow
ah I just touched that
it's like a mosaic of semen
look at that ah disgusting oh look at
the lampshade and look at that how can
they charge money for people to sleep in
this filth
wow
this is definitely a night
just sleeping bag
right lights out
[Music]
oh
come it's like trying to sleep above a
nightclub
oh [__]
holy [__] I'm gonna jump out the window
[Music]
it's crazy
[Applause]
[Music]
it's my first night at Oregon's
Applegate Lodge and there's no way I can
sleep over this Dreadful noise I've had
enough
[Applause]
thank you
hey Gordon yeah I'm trying to get this
thing up there you've got two seconds
yeah thank you
this is insane come on thank you
um how on Earth is anyone supposed to
sleep with that racket
[Applause]
can you get the family together yeah
yeah and do we just have a a meeting
together
holy [__]
I don't know what to say I'm I'm
struggling I've never seen anything
quite as shoddy as I've experienced
today and I I I'm wondering why this
place is still open how much money do we
make tonight how much money did you make
about 1500 bucks 1500 how much money do
you make tonight
a couple hundred a couple of hundreds
about 500 but with all the noise
complaints Joanna had to comp three
rooms isn't that right absolutely you
two make a profit but your mother loses
money
does not make sense nobody said we were
sensible people
oh we're just blessed people having a
million dollars in debt is not blessed
first of all you don't understand what
you're talking about you're talking
business you're a businessman where's
the business I'm not a businessman and
I'm not trying to TC people to be the
business people it's this is our home no
one knows the difference between a hotel
and a home
and does anyone else know how much
stress and pressure you're under
um you know I do what I have to do to
keep the doors open you know can we just
quit talking about money Richard why
can't it be financially secure so that
both financially no Richard we are not
you can laugh at this and laugh at that
and we just want to make everybody happy
man listen it ain't an issue with me
you're refusing to look at the issue
because you and your sons are taking
advantage of Joanna
no it's not an issue so why are you
talking so much [__] it's not
[__] everything you say to me I'm
just ignored I'm gonna knock him on his
ass but you think I care what you think
about me Richard
don't you go have your cigarette I'll
grab my cigarette and relax a little bit
and we'll come back and then discuss
this
yeah
I'm not going to argue with your father
I'm just going to call it as I see it
this Lodge needs to be run by a business
and when I listen to your mum stressing
out about payments and you too going off
running your own little businesses
because you two are button heads
[Music]
it's a [__] disgrace
this [__] has to stop
because right now
this lady's suffering
yet your heads are so far in the [__]
sand that no one can actually see the
damage you're causing
my worst nightmare is that Duke and
Dusty never can get on the right page
and and I'm stuck till I'm 90 years old
trying to run this place and then I die
and it's gone I'm not a miracle worker
if you want this place to survive you
need to come together as a family and
run this place as a proper family
business
it is way past everybody's bedtime I've
seen the morning good night
[Music]
this place is insane I mean
I've never seen such a badly Run Lodge
in all my life and the one person I feel
sorry for is Joanna everybody else
they think it's a big joke I'll tell you
what I'm not [__] laughing
[Music]
with all the parting going on at this
Lodge I hardly got a wink of sleep
this Lodge is in a dreadful State and I
think everyone's blind to it that has to
change
you okay my darling yeah
uh there's something I want you to
understand because I think the only one
who can actually appreciate some things
that's been going on here
yeah yeah will you come up with me what
he might be showing me next I don't know
how much Universe it could get
hello everybody uh thank you so much for
coming this is Joanna she is the owner
um these are esteemed guests that have
been staying in your Lodge
I need to hear the truth and so does
Joanna let's start off with you madam
please uh me and my boyfriend stayed
here a few days ago both of us weren't
really pleased we were all the way in
the Myrtle Suite so we were the closest
the bar and we could hear it like we
were next to it my apologies I'm sorry
please Madam sir we got the honeymoon
suite and the bathroom wasn't clean so
we you know I cleaned it and
it just kind of grossed us out the fact
you had to clean the room before you
tried to relax it's insane
Madam please we got into bed and felt
something I
have underwear dirty underwear oh my God
I am mortified that is completely
unacceptable did you have any
interactions with Richard Richard
invited us to the back room what in the
like the buttha yes
to do what there was marijuana in the
back
he offered which we did not partake so I
can guess into the butt room and offer
them
marijuana it's not a hippie commune it's
a it's a lodge I know
I thank you for your time
[Music]
the yes feedback has hit Joanna hard and
now she's asked to speak to me alone
I wanted to show you this book it's the
building of the lodge and kind of see
what we went through oh wow from the
beginning from the beginning yeah wow
we built it with our hands we fell the
trees we hand peeled the poles we did it
all and it's it's an amazing Story how
we pulled this together I think if you
understand the struggle that we went
through to get it to this place you
understand why I'm so
fired up about keeping it and and having
it run wow
Top Notch and this is this is sort of
ground zero this is Ground Zero yeah
that's that's the butt head actually
seriously that's incredible and the kids
you know they were all here we grew up
here they're they're attached to it it
means so much to them
and I mean it's clearly your your little
Paradise but I don't think it's been
Paradise for guests but that's all Gonna
Change yeah wow look at that and they
lived happily ever after that was my
dream and I think that could still
happen it is going to happen please yeah
let's go and do this okay you're back
I'll see you shortly okay thank you for
that sure now I can see why Joanna loves
this Lodge so much and I know that to
save this place I need to get her sons
talking again clearly their dad's not
gonna make that happen he he's too busy
doing nothing come in a minute so I've
got to find a way to get these brothers
on the same page
so can you guys get this thing settled
once and for all I can't talk to him
though and have him not want to punch me
okay I've been being bullied my whole
life Gordon what are you talking about
you you really think that you haven't
done anything what have I tell me tell
me what I've done tell me what I said to
you that hurts you so bad because you've
said so many things to me you've
resented me you've told me I'm a punk
you said I'm a white trash tweaker
you're living like one I'm ashamed that
you're my brother
serious statement
this is horrifying you know go ahead
just leave no get the [__] off this
property did you guys get along ever was
there ever a Time
[Music]
horrifying oh God just leave no
did you guys get along ever get the [__]
off this problem remember a time
when is somebody gonna say [__] it this
isn't about my big brother my little
brother this is about my mum
[Music]
right the agent has to stop
I agree the hatred has to stop
yeah if we don't figure this out we're
going to lose the lodge
I don't want that at all
Dusty
why have we let this go on for so long
and I love you and I
don't want to see you hurt ever
I'm sorry
it's been such a long road with Duke
that you know I've just been been
praying every day for something to
change because it taxes my mother so
much
I am so relieved to hear that from both
of you you okay yeah
[Music]
now that Duke and Dusty have seen the
pain they've caused their mother I
believe they're going to be willing to
put their issues aside to save this
piece of paradise
this Lodge has so much potential in this
beautiful setting
[Music]
it's somewhere I'd love to bring my wife
and four kids for a vacation
it would be a tragedy if Joanna and her
family lost it what an absolutely
beautiful place to go for a swim but
there's still one problem I need to
tackle to make sure this Lodge has a
future it deserves
it's time to talk business
take a seat
um Richard
there's a business meeting okay you're
not really involved running the business
right okay and I think you need to let
these guys deal with the business so I
would ask you to disappear
you're a nice guy you're not going to
change and you know what I don't think
your family want you to change it loves
you as you are yes okay so I want you to
have a relaxed afternoon cool thank you
that's why you're here well I appreciate
it I've been talking years you take care
okay okay see that thank you Richard
right now it's not your time young man
and it's not your time do you know whose
time it is
that's right
that's right and she's at the helm but
she can't do without you that's right
all the personal [__] you leave when you
walk through that door because it's
about business now yeah we've never had
that
you have the possibility of turning this
around
Joanna what have you got to say I just
really need you guys both
you know I tried for many years to do
this on my own but you know what it's
time maybe you guys to help out a little
more
let's get this thing going man let's
roll you realize how freaking lucky we
are to have this place
boys are both of you committed to
working together and getting this place
turned around
yeah I'm learning if you're in it
absolutely man as businessmen and then
Brothers we figure this out with the
other [__] out okay
okay all right
it just warms my heart to watch the boys
Embrace and and to to see that they
really want to to work together and to
help grow this place again
[Music]
I've always been lifted off my shoulders
right now and now that we're actually on
some sort of a
they're going somewhere with it I am
just like stoked
these are tears of joy not sorrow thank
God there's a lot more changes coming
tomorrow thank you Joanna thank you
I thought Gordon was coming here to fix
the lodge but he ended up fixing our
family which is amazing
thank you thank you I'll see you later
okay
coming up welcome to the new Applegate
River Lodge I can't believe it
welcome to the new Applegate River Lodge
from this day forward we will run this
as one business yes as a restaurant yes
it's a music venue but they are all part
of the lodge business and they
contribute to the overall Lodge finances
understood understood because I cannot
wait for you to see through those doors
you ready yeah let's go
whoa oh my God oh my gosh wow oh nice
wow holy smokes
this looks like a lodge wow oh my god
when I first got here I had to sit on
the floor us now your guests will feel
warm and very welcomed yes absolutely
wow the lobby actually feels like a
Lobby now the leather couch is
incredible and rocking chairs I mean
people can come down in the morning have
a cup of coffee they can sit down it's
amazing is it gorgeous it's beautiful
yeah I love it come over the reception
desk is something else I want to show
you
here is the magic
oh
yeah I have given you a stunning brand
new hotel management POS point of sale
system so now your guess can check in
online wow it works in here it works in
the restaurants and it's going to tap in
to your music as well perfect I love it
yeah system it's going to really change
everything we do here Gordon has just
he's synced everything up and made this
one business it's really what this place
is needed for so long now could I see my
room yes absolutely let's go
there we go go straight through oh
cute look at this wonderful oh it's
gorgeous oh nice oh it smells so good in
here too I love it wow so the room is
fresh it's vibrant it's warm and I've
had all the carpets cleaned so there are
no more stains
nice the curtains are gone my 16 year
old curtains oh it's nice is it
beautiful very nice the disgusting
bedware all gone and with the blinds
guests no longer need to stare down a
Rich's butthole
this is
the Catwoman room looks like a really
classy place now I mean the bad the
Furnishings the lamps it's
not all that funky stuff I had in there
for years
oh I love it stunning one last thing I'd
like to show you at the restaurants are
you ready yep yep let's go we've got
some exciting things happening there
welcome to the new Applegate River Lodge
menu the menu's small the menu is
dynamic and the better the ingredients
the less that needs do to them let's
start off with the top shall we half a
roasted chicken and a lovely Sage lemon
butter sauce next to that the wild king
salmon with Citronelle and grilled lemon
and then finally 12 ounce New York strip
stunning I like it it's simple but it's
it's perfect now sit down and enjoy
[Music]
I love this menu because it's us have we
ever had dinner all together it really
hasn't happened yeah
coming up wishes you not believe what
I've done with your butt hot oh [__]
with the Davis Family ready to work
together
and the stunning new changes to the
lodge I've got one more surprise for the
family that will take this hotel to a
whole new level
this one you're gonna love oh that's so
cool
now this is everything you need to put
on a mini music festival for your guests
oh I can't believe it
here's the exciting news all of a sudden
the lodge has four extra bedrooms no way
oh no oh my gosh oh
wow yeah that's too good wow coupled
with a new outdoor grill so the guests
can enjoy a phenomenal barbecue lunch
while they enjoy the show now the music
business the lodge the restaurant will
work together and all the elements of
the business will be making money to
help pay down the debt and keep this
place open for decades to come I'm
completely excited and ready to start
doing music outdoors and I think it's
really going to be a great way for the
lodge and the restaurant and the music
to unite wow now Richard you not believe
what I've done with your butt hat you
ready
only joke you haven't touched that I
think
you don't want to go in there
it's time for the new and improved
Applegate Lodge to open to the public
while Dusty and Cami deal with the meals
Duke and Melissa handle the
entertainment with their combined effort
much needed revenue is coming into the
lodge and with the music on the outdoor
stage the entertainment is far enough
away for guests to enjoy their rooms buy
it feels like we're away from everything
now that the relaunch is a success I've
got to hit the road
Gordon It's Time to Say Goodbye it's
been a slice of Heaven A Little Slice of
Heaven serious yeah but please do not
offer any more gas some of those special
herbs already you built this place right
now let them have it or gladly okay it's
been an absolute pleasure
my time is done look after each other
and forget the past where were you
brother and take some weight off your
mother's shoulders yeah and this place
is Gonna Roll thank you so much
if Gordon didn't come we'd be in the
same stagnant environment with uh no
love and a lot of anger those boys need
to know who's boss they will good luck
thank you so much okay there's just no
words that can express how grateful I
feel for this awesome amazing experience
good night bye-bye
to leave this place
sorry to see the back of Richard's
butthole
[Music]
this is my visit to the Applegate River
Lodge Dusty and Duke continues to get
along and they're helping Joanna get
income for the lodge to reduce their
debt if you want to get all the trash
I'll get all the dishes uh okay this
family-run hotel is finally running
smoothly I feel like this is the first
step to taking the lodge into a
destination Resort which is what it
needs to be we should spend more time
together as a family you know yeah
Gordon has given us an opportunity of a
lifetime and we're not going to let him
down
I want to thank Gordon
for having the love in his heart to come
here
put my family back together
that's what I want
love you love you
[Music]
the hotel Chester is located in
Starkville Mississippi home to the
Mississippi State University husband and
wife David and Suki molendor bought the
hotel in 2000 before buying the Chester
David traveled the world as a hotel
troubleshooter I work in the hotel
industry 39 years
thank you for calling Hotel Chester I
wanted to try and settle down and give
our kids one stable place to be
one of us got to get taller to begin
with a 36 bedroom hotel was a real
success packed with students and locals
how you doing good
then a sudden tragedy hit the family
David was coming home and was involved
in a a major auto accident we thought we
lost him
that changed all of us it's overnight
he crushed his feet and was bedridden
for almost six months
[Music]
good in David's absence standards
dropped and customers stopped coming
well we were losing so much money that I
had to file for bankruptcy the financial
losses have been so bad the bank
foreclosed on their home so now they're
living in the hotel living in the hotel
working together in the hotel I retired
and I feel
out of sync with the world
they couldn't afford payroll so tsuki
left her job in real estate and took
over as chef and temporary manager it
was
in restaurant kitchens before in my
entire life but I knew how to make the
sushi
my mom's confused but despite her best
intentions with no formal training oh
she's struggling
where's my knife so Okie spends all her
time in the hotel so she's blind to the
tens of thousands of students and
tourists who could be potential
customers and the hotel's bedrooms and
dining room are empty most nights I just
need those entrees yeah but I guess
they're coming you know I see it in my
parents right I see that they're
physically exhausted that they're
mentally drained my mom she used to be
Lively vibrant she's honestly half one
she used to be man I forget I'm losing
my mind when I came to this place I was
180 pounds at Twisted blue steel sex
appeal and mucho hell then this old
[__] has worn me down to 200 pounds of
slab gab and total no mas
with almost no money coming into the
hotel David and Suki are hanging on by a
very thin thread
I need Gordon to help my parents because
if this hotel doesn't change it's we
lose everything this is it
[Music]
I'm in Starfield Mississippi's college
town I'm on my way to the hotel Chester
Mississippi State University founded in
1878. any hotel with a college on their
doorstep should absolutely thriving not
just for the students but with their
parents as well I can't wait to check
into the hotel Chester
I can't even see the sign
s I'm pulling over here got to know
where it is
how are you
I'm looking for the hotel Chester I've
never been there before now I'll find
out three times it's easy to miss easy
to miss yeah I can't see any signs well
there may be one time but yeah I mean
it's not right it's not too big
thank you enjoy
the students never go to the Chester
despite the fact it's right next to the
campus weird there we are there
Historic Hotel Chester entrance well
such a huge building and such a tiny
sign it's Madness finally
Monica hey how are you how are you good
to see you good to see you and I'm David
Davis I see well
I finally found the place that is so
confusing there you know that there's no
sign on Main Street I drove straight by
yeah on the corner of the building a
tiny sign is historic that that's what's
historic about it that's historically
been a bad entrance
now we have you in an executive King
room and then here's two keys for you
because I'm giving you two because men
don't follow instructions as well as
women or in case you get lucky hell yeah
up
so your hands on odor uh you run the
desk all by yourself my wife is the chef
she's taught herself the meats lady well
can I finish my Spiel I thought you
already finished so uh breakfast is
included we do have fresh cut fruit and
it's nice to know fresh cut fruit we
ought to be the alternative canned
no uh no fruit I think
I love your sense of humor it's dry and
very funny
fresh cut fruit for breakfast yes sir
nice now I just want you to know I'm not
always at the desk okay but you'll be
able to recognize me even if I'm walking
away from you because I'm the one who
looks like he's riding a chicken riding
a chicken yeah I've never ridden a
chicken you have to show well you just
have to look at my legs oh geez
I'll go get Suki okay grace that poor
chicken
canal
[Music]
ah it's so hot
I've got a guest that wants to meet you
what do you do with that I
Gordon is here to help us out and I'm
terrified but at the same time I'm so
excited okay hello how are you nice to
see you and don't worry I've had worse
than wet hands nice to meet you I washed
my hands there's very kind of thing for
that
right nice to meet you as always good to
see you too what's it like working with
your wife I love my wife so it's nice to
be around her until she gets her nose
out of joint she has a chef's
temperament if she's not familiar with
it right they can fly off the handle
pretty easy
what's your background I'm a hotel guy I
was in Vietnam and I went to Hotel
school to qualified as a hotelier well
I've saw in my view yeah good to hear
graduated with a major in hotel and
restaurant management and I've been in
the business almost 40 years so in a
nutshell what's wrong with the hotel
that's a question we're not sure we
don't think it's a quality fishing
neither for our rooms or our food and
beverage what do you both show me to the
room okay I've been a general manager of
a lot of hotels I eventually became a
turnaround guy to take on problem
properties so my big surprise here is
that I'm having a hell of a time trying
to turn this thing around we just call
it in the executive King
oh dear okay this is it yes sir what is
that swing
it's a leather but it's a rough leather
and very difficult to clean I was so
Bland I mean it's like a cheap motel
chain I feel like I'm in the witness
protection program
missing here so when was the last time
the roof were touched
2003 2003 so 10 years ago it feels like
something out of the 1970s our hotel
rooms are updated you know we try to
call it period Furniture yeah I don't
know what to say always tells you that a
place is on the decline when you walk in
you've got rules that are a mess scuffs
everywhere and big marks on the sofas
that you expected to pay good money to
sit down in so far I'm not digging it
I'm gonna unpack and then like to come
down and have a bite to eat Suki so
what's your experience in the kitchen my
father had a sushi restaurants in
Washington DC parents of a Japanese
restaurant had my father passed away of
course did you work in the kitchen no
just washing dishes
[Laughter]
anyway this I'm gonna unpack thank you
okay good to see you likewise
okay thank you
so you know I feel like the guy who
walked into a bar with a big frog on his
head went up to the bar and asked the
bartender for a drink and the bartender
said man I tell you you got a problem
don't you and the Frog said yeah I sure
do can you cut this wart off my ass
Batman talk
bars and restaurants in a vibrant
college town like this are always packed
at lunchtime but this place is dead I'm
Lindsay how are you good there you go
I'm gonna get you something to drink
Jefferson ice cold water okay please
would you recommend Strawberry Fields
Sushi is very popular it's a little bit
sweeter I'll try it Las Vegas as an
appetizer as well and then oh it's cool
five individual rolls rolled into one
[Music]
I don't know how you execute all that
Japanese food on that menu when you're
not trained it doesn't quite make sense
oh my goodness this is not good there's
not a lot of people in Starkville that
like our Sushi it's a little bit
different from what other places in
Starkville have
[Music]
oh
got that slow
[Music]
Suki runs her kitchen the way she wants
to it's always takes too long in between
tickets but there was really nothing I
could do about it this food is taking
way too long I've been waiting over an
hour for raw fish
oh my God I can't take this anymore
damn it
I'm at Starkville Mississippi's Hotel
Chester and I've been waiting for my
lunch for a very long time
[Music]
damn it
I nodded off there oh my God does the
sushi usually take this long yes sir
what is this one Las Vegas oh my God
cheese and asparagus and then it's deep
fried and comes with the jalapenos
fried salmon with cream cheese
disgusting
strange combination very weird it
doesn't work for me that one I mean it's
just greasy
um you can get this out of the way as
quick as possible okay thank you you're
welcome
my first impressions of the food here is
that it's as bad as the rooms
Sakura and there's cream cheese in the
middle
look at that thing so it's pretty big
right so how are you supposed to get it
in your mouth
I've never eaten it before let's try
come on me we're in this together
that's yours
really open wine please wait there is no
way this is gonna fit my mouth ready one
two three
I can't do it
now I know how my granddad feels he puts
a new teeth
can I throw it away now
so you took one little bite I did damn
disaster total disaster how did it taste
by the way I'm very good the Sakura is
very chewy Suki does tried her best but
she has no idea what she's doing what's
wrong with the Sakura Bland ugly chewy
strange combination chewy
yep and impossible to put in your mouth
let me tell you about my sushi I'm not a
Morimoto or Noble absolutely I'm doing
my best and I respect rice what is this
one strawberry field now look at that
strawberry on sushi
Japanese Chef in America I'd like to
apologize
it's very weird which part is so true
you wouldn't cover white tuna with
strawberries and then glaze it
Strawberry Fields I'd rather [__] eat
a beetle
[Music]
I am frustrated that Gordon does not
like I am I Sushi I've tried all I can
doing honey bun
he doesn't like any of it no
so truthfully what is wrong with this
place lack of business so on an average
weekend how many guests would you do on
a busy weekend maybe 12 people are they
in-house guests Hotel usually so
virtually nobody from the outside
correct Jesus
anyway we're the owners can you uh tell
me where they are sure thank you
they've got just 36 bedrooms you get on
a busy night just 12 guests eat here
with food that bad I'm not surprised
[Music]
congratulations on the longest lunch
I've ever had in my entire cooking
career
that was
97 minutes
here and half of it was raw as an
obvious cook why are you making sushi
it's crazy I'm trying my best to to at
least introduce Mississippi last year
there's nothing healthier with my lunch
maybe a health warning
surely you should be giving the locals
what they want to eat that's why they
come well talking to Lindsay the only
customers we get now are the ones
staying in the hotel which is
practically no one
the business is on his ass
how much debt are you in
over 900 000. nine hundred thousand
dollars right
we are in debt please don't say you
don't know
[Music]
so far Starkville Mississippi's Hotel
Chester has been a massive letdown Hotel
Chester entrance well such a huge
building and such a tiny sign the dated
solars rooms are awful it's like a cheap
motel chain
strawberry on Sushi the sushi is the
worst I've ever had it's hideous and
David the co-owner has just admitted to
me and to his wife that they're almost a
million dollars in debt nine hundred
thousand dollars right
wearing that please don't say you don't
know
I'm deeply sorry
and I'm I'm sad that you're upset
I'm that upset at you David should not
have been hiding the financial status
from me
finding out she's been kept in the dark
has angered tsuki Dave hell I I don't
know what we are doing I do the spending
side and you do the paying side
I don't share the finances with Suki
this is getting ridiculous because I'm
afraid of hurting Suki's feelings calm
down no I'm not gonna come down while
the owners argue guess who have heard
about my visits are arriving at the
Chester for dinner it's gonna go to the
restaurant it's just straight shoot
right back there all right and tonight
the Russian and hotel will be full of
people for the first time in years I
feel sorry for all of them how long they
should be waiting I would say at least
45 minutes 45 minutes my apologies I
haven't been waiting on so we've been
here over about an hour an hour
I'm sorry I've never seen anything like
this before it's insane how long these
guests are waiting so what type was this
Suki
oh pardon me I'm sorry I just asked what
table are you doing the very first table
the very first table
it's been well over an hour and tsuki is
only working on the first table
he's really struggling and yet Dave is
not stepping in to lend a hand
so yeah over an hour in the service
would you go in and help her
I would but you know that's just not my
territory right unfortunately it's like
the hotel's falling apart around you if
someone needs you in the kitchen in the
bar the reception shouldn't you be
multitasking their kitchen is hurt
territory I'm just asking is your hotel
I know and I appreciate that yeah if the
kitchen's not David's territory then
maybe the rooms are
if I touch the blinds and there's like
dust all over it kind of a beat up
family looks like I came out of
someone's house when they died it's
definitely not supposed to hang out it
seems to me that David has checked out I
don't understand what's going on here
this is not good Suki is totally out of
a depth having only dealt with one of
the eight tables waiting for food
oh no this is awful wow
they said it wasn't cooked
mom what's wrong
you okay
don't even want to get her in trouble
you okay I'm fine to help me understand
what's going on no I just
undercooked in the center no I know I
just like don't
know
um what is it that I'm missing the point
I don't understand why she's in there
playing head chef
because we don't have any
as in a car accident in 2008
he was bedridden for about six months
and then Mom moved in around the hotel
the next day my mom became a chef
overnight she
came to the hotel saw where she thought
she was needed and jumped in the kitchen
and ever since she's been trying to make
it work
so how long has it been functioning like
this I mean I think it's been in this
state for about two or three years my
dad has taken a step back
and given up a little bit okay we have
to be strong get some fresh air get your
eyes nice and bright okay
finally I get it the hotel Chester has
been in a tailspin since David's car
accident I wish Suki or David had told
me well
the beer garden interesting Suki is just
trying to make this work as best she can
but she is failing miserably and David
has Hotel knowledge but since the
accident he has taken a back seat this
whole place feels lost the owners the
restaurant the bedrooms even this Garden
feels abandoned just like the dinner
guests the customers are getting so
pissed off I'm gonna have to do
something otherwise this place is gonna
go crazy
[Music]
the hotel Chester in Starkville
Mississippi is on the brink of financial
disaster and I finally found out why my
dad was in a car accident in 2008.
David's car accident sent the hotel into
a sharp decline oh no Suki is drowning
in the kitchen trying to keep the
business afloat
I would say at least 45 minutes we've
been here over about an hour while our
husband David isn't taking the reins
I can't see the diner starve so I've
dashed over to the local supermarket the
least I can do to help poor Suki is to
cook up a few sliders before the
customers walk out
those diners nearly any food trust me
it's a name it's coming from me as
ridiculous in the an hour for appetizers
crazy
[Music]
from the barbecue in the garden I don't
want you guys washing away everybody got
some food now
feel a bit better yeah
the burgers have brought Suki enough
time to get through the rest of dinner
service without anyone walking out
after a long three hours everyone has
finally been fed I'm sure Suki is as
relieved as me that dinner service is
over
how are you Suki fine fine yeah that was
a tough one
it was very tough yeah yes sir why don't
you guys get out of here you go home
let's hook up first thing tomorrow
morning how far is home away from here
this is our home now bedroom what do you
mean this is your home we live here you
live on site yes
you have an apartment here no right in
there there's a handicap room
that's our that's our home now we live
in the handicap room yes can you show me
since there is an accident I gave up
everything we have no money
it's no choice but to live
to live you live in here yes
there's not even a [__] window no
tsuki I had no idea if things were this
bad well I have to do what you have to
do I'm so sorry well you know
sometimes you have the bad times
can you get David okay please I don't
know what else to do we have two
children I would like for them to be um
not to have to worry about their mom and
dad okay
so you were running this hotel this was
your baby that's right Davis yes and
sadly if you got involved in a
tragic car accident yes what happened
I broke both of my ankles and back in
two places
[Music]
lost him
I mean you know I was pretty busted up
so
I've been spending most of the past five
years just recovering
why did you sell your house we couldn't
make the payment and
you foreclosed yes that's terrible I'm
sorry I didn't know that and you come
home every night now into this bedroom
this is awful there is no way to live
I think you deserve something better
[Music]
I promise I'm gonna help you fix this
place
okay yes sir thank you Gordon thank you
will you get some rest please
sometimes I will go seven days without
stepping out of the hotel and it's uh
it's sad I can't believe David and Suki
have been living like this for years
I've never wanted to help two people so
badly I just hope I'm not too late
all right
that was a rough night's sleep
um I can stop thinking about David and
Zuki downstairs where they are almost
cooped up in that tiny room with no
windows and my sleep was rough but
Christ imagine going through there for
three years like let me do God
wow
David and Suki have sunk so far they
have lost sight of the outside world if
they lose this hotel then they lose
everything I need to show them the
potential of this place before it's too
late
it's like a sink
[Music]
come on this is ridiculous
need to see how to make the hotel
Chester a success I've got a plan you've
let this business swallow
the both of you up yeah it's like
quicksand you know you've lost your way
not only have you lost the connection
with each other but you lost a
connection out there
now there town the students
the community both come with me I've got
something to show you they can save the
life of your hotel
the car please
when was the last time YouTube went out
for lunch
I can't remember you've never been out
for lunch together no no wow I want to
show David and Suki a couple of places
that are extremely successful because
they tap in to what the community wants
thank you very much
it's usually busier actually on a
average weekend for instance um
can you believe a thousand people a day
here
good honest Mississippian food
you just won 100 people a day yeah
I did not know that there were that many
people eating out
I've got one more place to show David
and Suki to really make sure they see
there are plenty of businesses doing
well in the town as cool as this place
it's really popular you know since my
accident I really haven't gotten around
town you know this business is a hundred
meters from your front door thank you
now no please how many covers you doing
a day how many numbers
um about 200 today
and uh weekends generally double that
significant 200 guests today 400 of the
weekends and families as well early
evenings yes a lot of our businesses
revolves around uh students thank you
the purpose of this outing is to show
you how these businesses are drawing
from the University how they are open to
every market and it does translate to
the rooms you have a potential Gold Mine
sat there you have the traffic you've
got to tap into the community that's
what you're not doing
um
I thought we were always welcoming
students maybe we were wrong so let's
say yeah yeah definitely an eye-opener
now that I've shown David and Suki how
much potential there is in Starkville I
need them to commit to turning the hotel
Chester around
that was nice I enjoyed that yeah I did
too to see it that busy for lunch was
incredible
booming there David you need to get your
head back in the game that's right I got
some great ideas but you too have to be
ready for change
Gordon whatever
Direction you help us to get on we're
not going to waver off of that
[Music]
when I arrived at Starkville
Mississippi's Hotel Chester it was
invisible on the Main Street Hotel
Chester entrance well so that's a huge
building and such a tiny sign and
failing to appeal to the people who
could make it a success the college
students I'm convinced Suki and David
are now ready for change whatever
Direction you help us to get on we're
not going to waver off of that
[Music]
so now it's time to reveal the new hotel
to David and Suki and their team
[Music]
picture is held on out to worry about
finding it now that's wonderful
welcome to the new hotel Chester you're
no longer hidden on the main street now
customers locals identifying that it is
a hotel is it big enough for you David
oh yeah I think it's really really great
yeah it's the biggest marketing tool
you'll ever need I love it
should we have a look inside
I'm looking forward to seeing what
Gordon has done with the inside of the
hotel are you ready
[Music]
wow jumping please this is definitely
lovely lovely lovely yes I love it John
is the drab and the dullness now this
room has character isn't this beautiful
I'm genuinely thrilled if I could I do a
somersault backwards and then if Gordon
had let me I'd kiss him and even if he
doesn't I may drag him in and give him a
big old kiss right on the damn lips
Megan nice to see that you're happy very
happy it's more than I can have hoped
for and it seems to be the beginning of
the end of our struggle do you think the
parents of those 20 000 students
in the University we want to stay here
now yes all right now you see one more
room yeah yes yes let's go all right
oh my God
damn I love this room beautiful
I'm in a dream wonderful beautiful
beautiful I mean I can ask more this is
not a chain hotel this is your hotel no
that's right something to be proud of oh
that's awesome I've got something else
to show this one you're gonna absolutely
love ready so excited
[Music]
please I'd like to welcome you all to
your stunning beer garden there we go
this is what I call a beer garden damn
modern benches so we have communal
benches as well large parties families
additional space are there as well we
take advantage of stunning Furniture
that's nice beautiful I love it you're
going to the Gazebo we have the most
amazing local beers
craft beers on town and these stunning
craft beers that can rotate the local
beers to sort of promote stuff locally
that's awesome the beer garden is
awesome I'm going to Christen it myself
and somebody's gonna have to carry me
out of it before we open the doors to
the public
there's one more thing I'd like to show
you
please come with me yes I love this
Garden out here
welcome to New Hotel Chester's stunning
beer gardens food this hotel is in a
vibrant college town in the heart of
Mississippi so I've created a menu that
will attract a younger crowd and
highlight southern comfort food gone is
the fusion confusion
Suki I'm sorry all gone good southern
food fits the location how can we be in
Starkville and not have stunning fried
green tomatoes next to that we have
oyster bacon PoBoy five crispy oysters
crispy bacon with a stunning spicy
remoulade and Gordon's Burger he's a
chef and he from time to time comes up
with some stunning recipes with burgers
this burger recipe is featured in at
Pana Hollywood in Vegas and it is to die
for the new menu complements the state
of Mississippi I think it really suits
the beer garden wonderful wonderful idea
Suki I have something for you that's
going to make your life in the kitchen a
whole lot easier bear with you one
second please
now I've got someone I'd like to
introduce you to
someone who very special with two unique
assistants come through please say hello
to Enrique Williams now she'll be Hotel
Chester's new head chef this lady is a
very experienced chef and she absolutely
knows her stuff I'm covering Enrique's
salary
I'm taking care of that until this place
picks up and you can afford to keep it
yourself
[Music]
having Suki in the kitchen kind of broke
my heart every day so I'm really looking
forward to getting to know the chef and
her apprentices and giving them all the
support I possibly can I want you to
keep cooking but I want you to have a
bit of fun with it and here's how it's
going to work Suki's rebutter grilled
skewers chicken beef shrimp garlic
ginger soy mayonnaise that's a Robata
it's a personal touch I love it I love
the change Roberta is classic Japanese
barbecue when you think of a butter
Grill you think marinade is Japanese
Farm it's easy to execute and you know
what it cuts a little bit of slack in
the kitchen it gives the kitchen a bit
of time now all of you sit down and tuck
in thank you so much please thanks
Gordon that looks so damn good doesn't
it
with word out to the locals and the
college students about the Chester's new
Vibe this hotel is ready for business
what are y'all doing checking in yeah
as the new younger clientele begin
checking in it's clear the renovating
rooms are a hit
it feels so big and so bright just wow
we need one of these countries at home
while the rooms are proven to impress
the renovated beer garden is also
creating a bus with students parents and
locals
buy green tomatoes do you want anything
from the grill that's my uh my little
one and everything what are you drinking
buddy David seems reinvigorated as an
owner and is really getting into it let
me get your glasses now just call them
out to me I'm thrilled to death just
looking out there and seeing people
eating good food and drinking good craft
beers and conversing is exactly the kind
of environment I wanted out there I need
a burger medium a fish and chips
pulled pork and without Suki in the
kitchen the new head chef is doing a
fantastic job of making wonderful meals
and getting them out in a timely manner
that is it for high one so now we're
working high too and make him sweat God
damn it there you go all right buddy the
biggest thing Gordon has done is giving
me a new sense of confidence and an
opportunity to have my wife be my wife
again my favorite has been there
Gordon's hamburger and I'm not a
hamburger eater and it's a fantastic and
it's a money back guarante gotta give
you money back you couldn't like it okay
that's the best burger in Sparkle
without a close-up it is
now that the hotel Chester is catering
to what the locals want and with Suki
and David embracing the changes I know
my job here is almost done
Time to Say Goodbye
hey Gordon I'm gonna miss you both
we're gonna miss you too look after each
other Embrace these students their
parents
get this hotel full when I see you
behind that bar serving pints yeah that
for me is you and your elements all
right take care of yourselves yes okay
seeing you bouncing around out there
tonight happy in front of customers
rather than stressed good to see you
take care of yourself
wow
[Music]
I'm sorry I forgot one little thing can
you come with me please yeah one little
thing before I go
[Music]
the relaunch of the hotel Chester is a
huge success can you come with me please
yeah now Suki and David are on their way
to making this hotel The Talk of the
Town in the car place but before I leave
I have one more surprise for them
right there's one more little thing I
wanted to show you
in this place beautiful a gorgeous pool
there
both of you come in for two seconds
[Music]
now living in that tiny room with no
windows is not the way to live so
this is your new apartment
I rented this for the next six months
I'm sure when the business kicks off
you'll have sufficient funds to rent
this apartment oh I love it open plan
kitchen Lounge have a quick look at the
bedrooms through there beautiful this is
just what we really needed for Dave and
me to get away
thank you and some time out that is
yours thank you so much thank you thank
you again that's awesome
um just damn flabbergasted actually
being on sites and not having time out
of your hotel you are blind to the
potential on your doorstep was
ridiculous thank you we thought Gordon
was just coming here to help us with the
business he ended up being
helping us emotionally our marriage he
very much wanted for us to be together
and that was so lovely but for them also
no question about it really really nice
yes
thank you again now I'm going to hug you
too
I'll take care of you okay
spend some quality time together you
deserve it good night and good luck all
right bye Gordon
it's a new start for me and it's just
definitely a new start for Suki I'm
going to get naked in the pool right now
so nice to two people
finally happy
it's always on [__] sushi
what was she thinking
[Music]
since my visit the hotel Chester's
bookings have gone up have y'all stayed
with us before no this is the first time
and the guests are enjoying the new
improvements
feel special like it's it's actually how
to touch care into it
with a new menu and beer garden the
hotel has become a local hit with the
college kids
I mean it was outstanding was it yes I
mean the local Brewery Mississippi plus
you had a mix of everything oh so you
had the uh
the new Buzz around town means the hotel
Chester is now bringing in thousands of
guests every weekend I'm David and Suki
are working as a team again next March
8th what I booked for a reception for
about 150 to 200 people so they went all
over 36 rooms for two nights Gordon has
saved us our relationship with husband
and wife is better we'll be we are now
Partners
[Music]
what Gordon has done for us it means
everything to us and I think Jordan's
helped to put the hotel on the map
thank you